et depuis 2011 la radio est célébrée par
une journée mondiale chaque 13 février
c'est une date proclamée par les États
membres de l'UNESCO pour cet outil
impuissant pour je cite célébrer
l'humanité dans toute sa diversité qui
constitue une plateforme pour le
discours démocratique c'est ce que dit
l'UNESCO et c'est l'occasion pour nous
de rappeler que dans les Yvelines et
bien nous sommes gâtés en termes de
radiologie locale puisque près d'une
dizaine et mette encore aujourd'hui
elles sont associatifs certaines sont
nées dans les années à 80 même juste
avant dans le mouvement des radios
libres et pour parler justement de ces
radios locales yblinoises on a en
plateau avec nous deux invités Corentin
Alonso bonsoir bonsoir journaliste pour
Radio sensation qui émet dans les
Yvelines vous êtes basés à Élancourt sur
la fréquence 98.4 mais également dans
d'autres zones puisque la radio est
implantée en Essonne en Normandie et
émet aussi sur le DAB+ à Paris héros et
en face de vous il y a Jean-François
denage bonsoir vous êtes vous le
président d'Hervé vs pour Radio au Vexin
Val de Seine qui émet également dans les
Yvelines sur la fréquence 96.2 vous êtes
basé aux Mureaux je vais faire un
premier tour de table messieurs si je
vous dis radio ça vous évoque quoi
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous la
radio Corentin moi ça m'évoque les longs
trajets en voiture c'est ce qui
accompagne un petit peu c'est le moment
parfois quand on part en vacances
notamment et puis même les trajets du
quotidien
c'est surtout ça puis parfois j'écoute
aussi la radio le soir avant de
m'endormir ça te permet de déconnecter
un peu des des écrans mais de rester un
petit peu d'apprendre toujours des
choses et un côté mystère quand j'étais
jeune autour de la radio de pas savoir
forcément le connaître le visage du
présentateur il y avait toute une part
de mystère savoir ça représente quoi
pour vous la Radio la radio pour moi ça
représente l'information à la
communication surtout et puis des choses
que nous ne connaissions pas à l'époque
on a découvert avec la radio les
différentes musiques les différents sont
d'outre-mer et d'ailleurs c'est vraiment
vraiment agréable à écouter et puis
c'est vrai en vacances en vacances et
bien
de ces différentes radios que nous
écoutions et pas tant que maintenant
mais dans la voiture et bien on chantait
on était accompagné donc de radio
d'actualité et puis d'information oui
c'est finalement le média on se laisse
porter on s'intéresse à la voix avant
tout et on l'associe comme le disait
Corentin comme vous le disiez à des
souvenirs des souvenirs d'enfants
parfois des souvenirs et de vie pourquoi
à votre avis ça reste un média à part et
qu'il faut défendre face à d'autres
médias peut-être qui est aussi
complémentaire avec le média de la
télévision par exemple mais pourquoi
c'est un média à part selon vous la
médié à part parce que c'est un moyen de
communication on va dire assez facile
pour la proximité surtout voilà le comme
sur RVVS sur Radio avec Saint-Val de
Seine le droit de parole est donné un
peu à tout le monde à toutes les
personnes qui le souhaitent nous allons
donc sur différents forums sur
différents faits d'associations pour
justement aller à la proximité de des
personnes de l'auditeur qui a un message
à passer
le témoignage va être plus facile et on
va pouvoir faire des émotions dans la
voix qu'on et puis l'aspect télévisuel
la télé l'écran peut parfois faire peur
aux gens qui souhaitent témoigner parce
que à la radio on va avoir plus
facilement alors vos deux radios sont
nés dans le mouvement des radios libres
alors avant le 9 novembre 1980 qui est
la date de la libéralisation des ondes
les radios étaient soumises à un
monopole d'État pour RVVS on parlait à
l'époque même de radio pirates c'est né
d'une émission pirate en 1979 on vous
avait reçu sur ce plateau pour parler de
vos 40 ans 40 ans également pour Radio
sensation puisque la radio est née en
1982 sous le nom de triangle FM qui est
devenu donc radio sensation c'était en
2009 l'esprit radio libre à votre avis
Jean-François denage duquel est né
finalement rvbs c'est ce qu'il a encore
présent aujourd'hui il est encore
présent il est encore présent et ça je
le confirme et on y tient beaucoup cette
cette liberté de de parole de
communication et cette proximité avec
toutes les communautés puisque radio
avec ça Val-de-Seine c'était à la base
donc c'est la base de la radio c'est la
puériculture enfin le pluralisme
toutes les communautés sont représentées
il y a différentes émissions qui sont
représentées dans cette radio et
justement ce droit de parole qu'on ne
retrouve pas ailleurs j'insiste
là-dessus puisque les
radiocommunautaires on en a pas tant que
ça et sur une seule radio on a plusieurs
communautés et ça c'est une richesse
c'est une richesse d'expression droite
parole et Corentin de disait aussi plus
de facilité pour les personnes
interviewées de de s'exprimer et aussi
différents sujets à aborder on va en
parler dans un instant mais on peut
parler tout aussi à la radio exactement
nous à Radio sensation on parle vraiment
de tous les sujets que ce soit de la
culture soit le tissu associatif qui est
hyper riche dans la plupart des villes
on essaie de le mettre en avant alors
les associations c'est qu'elles soient
sportives économiques les politiques
aussi on essaye de faire vivre le débat
le débat politique au niveau local ce
qui est important d'avoir des médias
locaux pour faire vivre la démocratie et
puis on a aussi cet aspect européen qui
est devenu un petit peu
l'ADN de radio sensation de fabrique de
radio sensation avec beaucoup
d'émissions réalisées un peu partout en
Europe c'est ça depuis quelques années
maintenant avec Nicolas Kiri Lovitz que
vous connaissez bien ici à 78 qui a donc
eu cette attrait pour l'Union européenne
on le sait l'Union européenne c'est un
sujet qui est extrêmement peu médiatisé
aujourd'hui en France il y a un déficit
de notoriété que ce soit sur les
institutions que ce soit sur les
politiques menées rares des sensations a
fait le choix de de faire donc des
programmes de développer des programmes
pour justement informer et faire le lien
entre l'Union européenne et le local le
très local car il y a des liens qui qui
peuvent faire puisque l'objet va être
fait finalement c'est dire l'Europe agit
directement sur le quotidien des
Yvelines noires par exemple je vais
prendre juste un seul exemple il y a
bientôt le Salon de l'Agriculture à
Paris bah l'Europe c'est un tiers de son
budget c'est la politique agricole
commune c'est la Pâque et la PAC c'est
ce qu'on mange tous les jours dans nos
assiettes donc il y a ce projet en
Europe il y a les honorable un très
régulièrement enregistré qui sont aussi
diffusés sur TV 78 un projet aussi
autour de l'amitié franco-allemande qui
est mené en ce moment à Radio sensation
alors on a mené avec le fond citoyen
franco-allemand qui nous aide beaucoup
pour financer nos projets d'émission on
a été à Berlin faire une table ronde sur
la grossophobie on a été donc à bord
ville jumelée avec Saint-Germain-en-Laye
dans les Yvelines pour donc créer des
liens avec une autre radio locale là-bas
justement aussi en Allemagne il y a
tellement de choses qu'on peut faire
avec la radio même même aller traverser
les frontières mettre en avant les
associations au travers des mailles on a
vu quelques images l'hebdos politiques
aussi que vous animez qui interroge des
des personnalités politiques du
territoire imminent et aussi du
territoire francilien et Corentin a
utilisé le mot lien j'ai l'impression
quand même c'est un mot très fort dans
la radio notamment à Hervé vs le lien
aussi entre les différentes vous avez
commencé à parler tout à l'heure ces
différentes communautés qui composent
aussi ce territoire yvelin il y a des
émissions dédiées par exemple à la
culture italienne également des
émissions aussi sur sur les DOM-TOM il
me semble tout à fait il y a des sièges
au soleil DOM-TOM il y a la culture
italienne les Serbes aussi qui ont qui
ont une émission il y a le CD Sénégal
enfin le Sénégalais qui ont une émission
justement le peuple qui qui communique
aussi en direct via le Sénégal par
Internet bien sûr mais voilà c'est tout
cette communication alors je n'irai pas
jusqu'à l'Europe puisque nous sommes
restés vraiment local comme vous savez
nous sommes nous sommes des bénévoles
une quarantaine de bénévoles
une seule salarié qui est la secrétaire
d'ailleurs que je salue qui fait des
montages qui fait qui fait un peu tout
qui est secrétaire qui est employé mais
qui fait aussi beaucoup de choses pour
pour l'association et et il est vrai que
pour la la communication nous avons un
journaliste pour tout ce qui est
actualité tout ce qui est actu homme
politique de proximité etc que ce soit
pour les municipales ou les
présidentielles par exemple on a
Monsieur Robert Congo qui qui gère qui
gère toute cette partie en tout cas
c'est la radio de proximité
est très importante je le ressent avec
les auditeurs les les personnes qu'on
nous annonce sur différentes
manifestations et bien ils viennent
toujours vers la radio parce que c'est
un moyen de communication pour eux et
ils y tiennent et c'est vrai que pour
aborder les les grandes radios c'est ce
qui me disent toujours on va passer sur
d'autres radios ce n'est pas évident
tandis que là on va vers eux ils
viennent vers nous donc il y a un
échange qui apporte beaucoup de choses
et beaucoup de richesses culturelles sur
les ondes un Cortez à côté formateur
aussi il y a Laurent Romejko qui a
débuté sur RVS qui ont débuté sur RVS
Laurent qui est passé il y a pas très
longtemps revoir un peu les studios etc
c'est un temps plein on reçoit beaucoup
de beaucoup de jeunes d'écoles de
journalistes qui sont là des jeunes de
stagiaires de 3e aussi qui viennent on
en avoir ce moment qui qui vient une
semaine en découverte et puis d'autres
qui reviennent par la suite parce que ça
accroché et donc c'est un tremplin pour
les futurs journalistes mais en face de
vous d'ailleurs Corentin qui débute sa
carte de journaliste qui débute à
sensation j'en suis aussi quelque chose
puisque j'ai commencé à Radio sensation
il y a forcément un côté formateur je
voulais terminer avec une dernière
question très générale est-ce que la
Radio la radio associative locale un bel
avenir devant elle selon vous Corentin
bah oui tant que tant que les élus
locaux aussi s'impliquent dans ces
médias tant qu'il s'investissent c'est
ce genre de radio ne peut que avoir de
l'avenir puisque il parle des citoyens
de l'actualité locale et c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui un outil de démocratie
important après c'est dans la main des
élus locaux qui financent avec les
subventions et puis le ministère de la
Culture aussi avec les subventions
notamment du du FSEA oui les élus locaux
très important les subventions les
subventions alors chez nous il y a pas
de publicité donc voilà ce sont les
subventions qui qui nous font vivre en
ce moment les c'est quand même difficile
avec tous les augmentations
d'électricité etc je le dis parce que
oui on a encore de l'avenir on est
encore là on va se battre pour voilà
mais il faut pas lâcher surtout pas
parce que c'est un outil de proximité
très important pour la population merci
Jean-François Denain merci Corentin
lonzo être venu célébrer en plateau
cette journée mondiale de la radio bonne
fête à vous et merci encore d'être venu
sur ce plateau